yes
oh yeah
[Music]
good afternoon uh i know yesterday was
groundhog day but
let me start today's briefing uh by
saying the exact same thing i said
yesterday when i walked in i'm sorry
of course we were waiting for our white
house colleagues to finish their
briefing
which they just did so with that
let's get started we have a couple
things at the top first
today the united states and the russian
federation completed the necessary legal
procedures to extend the new start
treaty for five years
extending the new start treaty for five
years ensures we have verifiable limits
on russian icbms slbms and heavy bombers
through february 4th of 2026 avoiding a
potentially unconstrained
nuclear arms race new start limits every
russian nuclear warhead
that is loaded onto an icbm missile that
can reach the united states
in approximately 30 minutes the united
states will use the time provided
by a five-year extension of the new
start treaty to pursue with the russian
federation
in consultation with congress and u.s
allies and partners
arms control that addresses all russian
nuclear weapons
i would direct your attention to
secretary blinken's statement released
earlier today for additional details
second
we are closely monitoring peaceful
demonstrations against the appointment
of a new rector at boazici university in
turkey
we are concerned by detentions of
students and other demonstrators
and strongly condemn the anti-lgbtqi
rhetoric surrounding the demonstrations
freedom of expression
even speech that some may find
uncomfortable is a critical component of
a vibrant
functioning democracy that must be
protected
peaceful prosperous and inclusive
societies depend on the free flow of
information
and ideas the united states prioritizes
the protection of human rights
and stands shoulder to shoulder with all
those fighting
for their fundamental democratic
freedoms
so with that um why don't we get started
matt
thanks ted uh just on um
a new start um
this is one of these days where i
an unusual day where i didn't really
have anything that was
significantly um important i don't think
to to open with but
so i'll start with um new start
so you've completed this yes
do you not see that there's any kind of
um
dissonance in uh going ahead and
and extending an arms control treaty
with the russians at the same time as
you're criticizing them very heavily for
the situation with uh mr navalny
um and then secondly and i know you were
asked this
yesterday about open skies uh but also
on the inf i mean is
is there any as you look at arms control
with
russia going forward um
is there any thought in this
administration to trying to return
to those well so your first question
matt um
there isn't any dissonance uh and the
common denominator the nominator that
uh we are adhering to uh in this case
are our interests it is manifestly in
our interest
to have a full five-year extension of
the new start agreement
um you've heard us say this before but
as we engage russia in ways that advance
american interests as i just said um we
can also remain clear-eyed about the
challenges that russia
pose even his work with russia against
u.s interests so too
will we hold russia into account uh for
its reckless and its adversarial
um behavior you heard me um speak at
some length yesterday about the ongoing
review that the president is one of his
first
uh foreign policy actions tasked as
director of national intelligence
uh to conduct but i think the other
point that remains that um
especially when a relationship is
adversarial
um having something in place like new
start something that
puts those limits on uh russia's uh on
important elements of russia's nuclear
program becomes even more important
um uh uh frankly uh when it comes to
um you know broader arms control uh
treaties uh with russia
um you heard me say yesterday that uh
when it comes to the open skies treaty
um we're studying the issue we'll take a
decision in due course but
um to the best of our knowledge still
russia uh is not in full compliance uh
with the treaty obviously uh there have
been compliance issues uh with the inf
as well i think the the other issue here
is that
um what the new start extension does it
gives us time and space
uh to talk about the broader strategic
stability elements the arms control
uh elements that um we would like to uh
pursue
you just heard me say in that topper we
will use
uh the years that a new start extension
has provided
provided to us uh to focus on those very
important issues
okay and do those so then and and just
to expand it a little bit
further into um
north stream two in those sanctions
and when you say you're going to hold
russia to account
for navalny or for other
other issues are we talking about more
magnitsky sanctions
i'm not asking you for specifics but
well
again what are we talking about and can
you
can you address north stream too sure
and i'm done so
let me start with uh nordstrom uh two
section 232 of
of katsa uh the countering america's
advertary adversaries through sanctions
act
um as well as the protecting europe's
energy security act
um are powerful tools that help us
advance
u.s government policy uh nordstrom 2 and
the second line
of uh turkmenistan turks stream are
designed to increase russia's leverage
over allies and partners
and they undermine transatlantic
security the united states will continue
to work with our allies and our partners
to ensure europe has a reliable
diversified energy supply uh that does
not
undermine collective security that's
exactly why you've heard
um president biden even before the time
he was president biden when he was a
candidate
um say that nordstrom 2 is a bad deal uh
it divides europe it exposes uh ukraine
and central europe to russian
manipulation and it goes against
europe's stated energy security goals so
again this is one of those challenges on
which we'll
cooperate closely uh with our allies and
partners when it comes to
uh potential punitive measures including
sanctions against uh russian authorities
you heard me say yesterday that
it doesn't do us any favors to forecast
uh
potential targets or even really
authorities under which we might
um enact additional uh sanctions i'm
gonna save that for
um when that review is completed and
when we have additional sanctions or any
other punitive measures to announce
we'll do so
uh we'll go with the matt lee rule and
we'll stick with uh new start um for
wait that's not my rule but it's just
it's
it's not a rule i don't think the the
matt lee suggestion i thought it was a
good one
um so we'll uh we'll we'll stick with it
yeah this is a nordstrom
okay just
as you said secretary blinken said that
this is a bad idea
uh is it the administration's policy
that
this should not the pipeline should not
be completed and they will work towards
that
i just asked because there was reports
in the german media that they might be
looking to
to lift sanctions well i don't think we
can be
any clearer it's a bad deal um the uh
president biden uh
has said that i think what we can say is
that we will monitor activity to
complete or certify the pipeline
uh and if such activity takes place uh
we will make a determination on the
applicability
of sanctions um all that said sanctions
are only one
of among many uh important tools here
and we will work closely with our allies
and partners
to reinforce european energy security
uh and safeguard against uh predatory
behavior including that of
russia in this case um sticking with new
start yes
or russia thank you so much for this
opportunity
recently the digital media news channel
bpi tv was subject to a raid maduro
ordered the station to cease
operation in the country immediately
threatening our team
with criminal charges as a result we
were forced to stop transmission
and producing content in venezuela what
message
can the state department send to the
maduro's regime
to stop these campaigns of arrest
harassment and repression repression
against the media
and another question some nation groups
and organizations
have said that the only way out of the
crisis
is to properly resume political
negotiation to start
a transitional process in venezuela we
receive
information that some people visited
washington dc to try to convince the u.s
of a dialogue process with the regime
had someone with the state department
participate
in a meeting related to this is the us
considering negotiations with the
venezuelan regime
thank you thank you well let me take the
prerogative to welcome you to the
briefing room uh
if i'm not mistaken you are gabi peroso
of vpi tv
um a venezuelan journalist who as you
said your independent tv station has
been shut down by the maduro regime so
we're
um uh very honored uh to have you here
uh to your first question um
the united states condemns media
censorship anywhere in the world
uh media freedom is essential to the
pursuit of a vibrant democracy and
responsive governance
nicholas maduro is a dictator there is
no doubt about that and media censorship
is a hallmark of dictatorships he and
those who support him have tried to
silence
journalists like yourself uh who report
the truth through
regime directed harassment intimidation
uh
and violence as well uh we condemn
censorship we condemn
blocking harassment other tactics to
stifle
independent media voices including the
recent shuttering of vpi tv
and harassment of six other venezuelan
independent uh
outlets we support journalists and other
democratic actors who are advancing the
struggle for
democracy uh in venezuela maduro's
continuing media crackdowns
severely limit venezuelans access uh to
accurate information
uh as a result uh more than five million
venezuelans
um live in a so-called news desert
um with insufficient access uh to
independent media i think the
the the broader point here is that only
a regime afraid of its own people
um would engage uh in such um practices
uh you mentioned um uh
our general approach to nicholas maduro
maduro and his regime
and we haven't had a chance to speak to
it in this context so i think it's it's
worthwhile
um the overriding goal the overriding
goal of the biden harris administration
is to support a peaceful democratic
transition
in venezuela through free and fair
presidential and parliamentary elections
and to help the venezuelan people
rebuild their lives and countries
and country uh venezuelans have a right
to democracy
and a government that promotes and
defends it just like everyone
else in this hemisphere um president
biden you have heard him uh
say this even before he uh was elected
president biden he understands the pain
that the current crisis in venezuela has
inflicted
on the people of venezuela and their
families
um again maduro is a dictator uh his
repression
corruption and mismanagement have
created one of the
most dire humanitarian crises this
hemisphere
has seen that is why this administration
is committed
uh to several principles um one
designating as appropriate
uh venezuelans venezuela for temporary
protected status
uh number two uh addressing the
humanitarian concerns of millions of
venezuelans
with international partners number three
targeting regime officials and their
cronies
involved in corruption and human rights
abuses and number four
again uh aiding and restoring a peaceful
stable democratic future for venezuelans
uh and the regime both through free and
fair elections
uh and a long-term economic recovery as
to how we're going to do that
um look i certainly don't expect uh this
administration to be engaging
uh directly with maduro um as we've said
we will work
through a number of um we will work with
a number of allies uh
and and partners um to bring about um
progress towards democracy uh in
venezuela uh we will do that with
um our uh partners uh in the region we
will do that with
our uh european partners and allies
we'll do that with the oas
we will do that through the lima group
um through a number of
fora like-minded fora that share the
same goals of bringing about
democracy and human rights and an into
this corrupt
corrupt dictatorship in venezuela
yes does the administration still
believe that juan guado is the best
person to lead the opposition of
venezuela
so the united states continues to
recognize the 2015
national assembly as the last remaining
democratic institution in venezuela
um and consistent with that the person
chosen by the national assembly
uh to be its president as the interim
president of venezuela won
yes sorry can i just put a fine point on
this you
mentioned the lima group and the oas
what other like-minded fora
are you talking about here well uh i was
using uh
you know as you know a very small number
of u.n members have
done this i have recognized glydo or
unrecognized maduro as the case may be
so
is there are there any other fora that
you're talking about well
uh so to name a couple here um the oas
has indeed taken a strong leadership
position um pressing for
a democratic transition uh in venezuela
uh the lima group um
uh we welcome its leadership uh to
further strengthen a regional coalition
to advocate uh for free and fair
elections i was using for uh um perhaps
colloquially um bilateral relationships
multilateralization that's two but i
mean so are there more i mean yeah
that's
two is plural i i accept that okay but
are there more that you can point to
i said four which are which are two okay
two working with our allies and partners
okay yes sean
maduro the previous administration said
that there basically should not be no
contact with
uh maduro other than perhaps on
logistical things like the status of the
u.s embassy there
is this administration willing to have
any sort of uh dialogue with maduro if
it advances the goals that you mentioned
again i i would expect that uh our
dialogue
uh will be with our like-minded allies
and partners as well as with
uh the national assembly juan guado um
as the leader uh chosen by that national
assembly
i i uh would not expect um any direct
contact with uh with maduro uh again
whom we consider
consider to be a dictator at any time
that's the current policy i'm i'm always
talking about current policy um i don't
want to
um clearly i'm talking about current
policy
but it is the policy we will not talk to
him or is the policy
we don't expect to call him any time
this week
uh i think it's a little bit of both uh
we certainly don't expect
any contacts with uh maduro
anytime soon again our focus is on
working with our allies and partners um
working with partners in the region uh
working with sorry
working with um uh through the flora
uh uh and not um through the regime
directly
and can you also bit of a backgrounder
on
the secretary's comments or to families
of people like um
the american veteran who's been taken by
a taliban
um i i would be happy too uh so let me
start um with that uh
second question and actually um i i will
um uh offer a little detail
um that yesterday as i think we read out
secretary blinken um held a
private video conference uh with a
family of us hostages and
wrongful detainees as we've said
bringing home
u.s citizens in captivity is a priority
for this administration it's also vital
that we continue to partner um with the
families
of those wrongfully uh detained and held
around the world um it was a meeting
that uh it was a virtual meeting of
course
um but as i understand it uh it it
included
a number of families went for about 90
minutes um uh the secretary i know uh
asked to be briefed on these cases is
one of his first acts
uh in office and as you can tell by uh
the meeting just yesterday uh he's
prioritized
the collective work of this department
including the special presidential envoy
for hostage affairs ambassador carson's
um uh the work we're doing around the
world um to see to it that americans who
are unjustly detained
are returned to their families and their
loved ones um as expeditiously as
possible
um we've talked a couple families who
are on that call the feedback was was
pretty positive uh but one of the things
that we've heard a couple times is
you know they're kind of asking what
this administration is going to do
differently when it comes to trying to
get those families released you know are
you going to
communicate more with the families on
the back end are you going to deal with
intermediaries is there something
that you can do that your predecessor
didn't do to try to bring those people
home
well um look i think this may be one of
those areas uh
where there will be some degree of
continuity of course um when it comes to
our efforts to
uh release americans who are unjustly
held around the world
um it is telling that ambassador
karstens served in the previous
administration he's continuing to serve
uh in this one um we think it's
important that there be continuity there
and obviously
um in his role he's achieved great
success um
i know the families have a tremendous
relationship um with with his office
um so uh we're always looking for ways
um to um be better partners to
the families uh when it comes to um
various policies of course the
department of justice
um has a role in that the national
security council has a role in that but
when it comes to the office here the
special president's
special presidential envoy for hostage
affairs um ambassador carsons will
continue um to engage
uh daily um uh with the families um i
know that
he has uh he's always on the phone um
working those cases i assume when it's
safe to do so he will again be back on
the road
um working those cases around the world
as well i'm sure you saw the report
paul whalen um in russia is unable to
uh reach out to the u.s embassy is
unable to be in contact with the us
embassy
uh and he is sick in prison did this
come up with the secretary
yesterday and his call with the families
and what does the state department plan
to do
to re-establish that communication well
i don't want to go into
uh either the uh identity of the
participants or the nature of the
conversation as you can imagine
um it was a a private um conversation
um uh and it's best uh left that way
when it comes to
um paul whalen uh the welfare and safety
of u.s citizens um
again it's our it's our highest priority
russian authorities convicted paul
whalen in a closed and secret trial
depriving him of a key protection and
that is transparency
uh the trial was a mockery of justice
russian authorities did not provide
evidence
and did not allow mr whalen uh to
produce witnesses in his own defense
uh mr weyland is now serving a 16-year
prison sentence in a russian
labor camp um we remained remain
concerned of course
for mr whalen's well-being and his
safety and will continue to speak out
on mr whalen's behalf until the russian
government finally does the right thing
uh and sends mr whalen home to his
family
u.s officials both here at the state
department in washington as well as in
moscow
regularly speak um with uh uh mr
whalen's family
um uh we are of course aware of uh his
health concerns as he raised
um we have been in touch um with his
family
and we're appealing to appropriate
government
government authorities uh in russia to
facilitate consular access
if it was a private conversation why did
you guys put a statement out of that
well
we this statement as you will know um
other identities or cases um uh and i
think
um as as your colleague just said
several of the families have been um
speaking to it as well uh yes um do you
have any reaction to the charges that
have been brought against aung san sushi
can you any update on whether or not u.s
officials have been able to get in touch
with her
well um again uh to recap where we are
um you heard us say yesterday that uh
what transpired
on february 1st in burma constituted
military
uh coup d'etat when it comes to what we
have seen take place
uh in in recent hours we are aware
of reports that state council and tsuchi
and president win mint
have been charged with crimes and the
national league uh for democracy members
of parliament have been ordered to
vacate nafta um we are disturbed uh of
course um
by these uh reports uh we call on the
military to
immediately release them all uh and all
detain civilian and political leaders
journalists uh and detain human rights
activists and to restore the
democratically elected government to
power
as president biden has said the
military's seizure is a direct assault
on the country's transition to democracy
uh and the rule of law
so has anyone been able to reach her or
other leadership in nld
uh my understanding is that we have not
had that contact and
about the conversation that um general
milley
allegedly tried to have according to the
pentagon um what was the the purpose of
of
trying to establish that call i need to
refer you to the to the pentagon for any
uh questions about
uh what the chairman um maybe attempt
before we move on
have you guys made any decisions sorry
about uh
specific aid suspension cuts or is that
still
under review uh so we the review is
ongoing um
matt as you just started yesterday um
you were right that we have moved uh
swiftly
uh to assess the uh facts and do the
legal analysis of this case we came to
that
uh designation of a coup um uh in very
short order
um but that uh result that uh review
is ongoing we'll be guided by our
long-standing commitment to the people
of burma
uh and their aspirations for democracy
peace justice development and human
rights
um continuing our support for the people
of burma is more important now than ever
even as we determine additional uh what
additional
um policy uh moves may be appropriate
for
uh those behind this coup yes
one more on you know
the continuing support for the burmese
people is more important now than ever
have you started a review of whether or
not the crimes against the rohingya
uh is a genocide uh so you heard uh
at the time secretary doesn't lincoln um
speak to um
uh uh uh note that he would uh undertake
such a review
i don't have any further details um to
reach out we've uh secretary blinken uh
has now been on the job um
just just a week today um so we're very
uh early as we have additional details
to read out
certainly uh certainly will anything
else confirmed a lot of other reviews
though why wouldn't you
confirm whether or not you've started
this one i just i don't have an update
um when we do
we'll let you know yeah um could you
comment on
whether you think china is going to be
part of an international response on
myanmar
um and any efforts that you're
doing at the moment to make that happen
and um
separately but related there's a delay
in the confirmation of
um your nominee for the u.s ambassador
to the u.n
is that affecting diplomatic efforts to
respond to the crisis in myanmar
well um on your first question um i was
struck by
uh what was in president biden's
statement uh i guess it was
uh early uh yesterday morning yesterday
morning he said the united states is
taking note of those who stand with the
people of burma
um in this difficult hour we of course
have been
working um assiduously around the clock
both here
at the state department as well as in
our embassies
uh around the world um again as i was
saying yesterday um with our like-minded
uh
allies and partners uh to ensure that
our response is
uh coordinated and that's appropriate uh
i'm sure um
at least i hope many of you saw the g7
foreign minister statement on the
situation in burma
uh that came out and i believe it was 7
am
here in dc the uk uh issued it overnight
it was a very strong statement um and
that was no accident it called
uh the events in burma aku um it also
said we call upon the military to
immediately end the state of emergency
restore power to the democrat
democratically elected government to
release all those unjustly detained and
to respect human rights
and the rule of law so um very
unequivocal there from
our g7 uh allies and and partners in
this case
um to your second question when it comes
to ambassador uh thomas greenfield look
if we are going to hold china uh to
account
we need a confirmed uh ambassador um to
the u.n a confirmed
united states permanent representative
to the u.n
ambassador thomas greenfield has been
sounding the alarm uh on china
for decades now um the biden
administration is prepared to
uh out compete the chinese across the
board including uh at the u.n and
it's important that to that end should
be swiftly confirmed yes
does the biden administration support
the one china policy
all right so
uh oh all right now we know it's going
to be in uh
no tomorrow it's only because i can't
answer whether you
uh no it is only because i want to be
very careful
um about uh my language here um
but yes the answer is that um uh our
policy
um uh has not um uh changed
um uh it has not changed okay
and then on iran um can you be sorry i
just want i was teeing off that mat
i i know nick but wait a second can you
just say that you support that the
dividing administration supports the one
china policy
yeah that's great of course guided by
the one china policy correct
okay uh on iran the
secretary has been saying and you from
this podium and saying
uh once iran comes back to the
compliance the us will abide by
its commitments under the jcpoa
question i have is the u.s left the deal
first
so why are you guys saying that it's
iran's responsibility to come back into
compliance before you do i mean
if if the united states abandoned the
deal isn't it
the us's responsibility to come back
into compliance first and then iran
would follow suit
well um i think it is also true that
iran has distanced itself from the jcpoa
in very profound ways
um as well as we have discussed so um
right now what we're doing is i alluded
to yesterday
um we are um doing exactly what you
heard from secretary desonite at the
time blink it um we are undertaking
careful um in close consultations with
our partners with our allies
uh with members of of congress um
uh there's been a proposition a
proposition that um president biden
um put on the table i am not um out here
to negotiate uh
in public um uh with um
any country um uh and we're not there
yet frankly um we are still undertaking
those close consultations
um with partners allies members of
congress and and we'll take it from
there but would that
would that include uh i mean are you
thinking about the possibility of
offering them some
signal some relief that would outside of
sanctions relief that would send a
signal about the seriousness of urine so
when it comes to those signals again
that's something we want to make sure
we've coordinated closely and calibrated
closely with partners allies and that
um we have consulted uh closely with
members of congress as well so
um again this is uh uh today is february
3rd we're less than two weeks into this
administration
um we were serious uh when we said that
we want to take those
undertake those um consultations with
with a range of
uh with a range of parties and that's
precisely what we're doing
uh is it the administration's view that
iran is uh about three weeks away from
having enough
enriched uranium for a nuclear weapon
and if so
where what is the assessment based on uh
so
any assessment like that um would be uh
necessarily classified
um i know there have been press reports
uh i know there was uh one press report
overnight that pointed to a six month um
breakout time uh i think what you have
heard us say we've heard us say a couple
things
uh number one um when iran was fully
complying with the iran deal
uh that time was 12 months now that iran
has been in a position to distance
itself
from those strict protocols that strict
uh verification and monitoring regime um
iran is closer
um the the that breakout time is shorter
um but i wouldn't want to uh
characterize that from here our goal um
consistent with our goal to
um keep iran's nuclear program in a box
and to ensure that it can never
obtain a nuclear weapon is to make that
breakout time uh as long as possible and
to have
uh those verifiable measures in place to
make sure that iran can never obtain a
nuclear weapon
and so when secretary blinken raised
this in his interview about
about weeks away he was just referring
to public media reports
he didn't say that i think you're
misquoting him what he said um
is that uh uh iran if left
on its current trajectory um could
one day um be within within weeks uh he
was not speaking about the present uh he
was speaking about
um a continuation of the status quo if
left unchecked um it's precisely why
we're approaching this with such great
uh urgency um again starting those
consultations um
right off the bat partners allies
members of congress still in iran yes
i'm sure you saw the reports yesterday
that iran had brought on more
centrifuges online and given that
this is a deepening of violations of the
jcpoa
given that you see israel come ahead
israeli officials close to netanyahu
saying
that with uh if iran gets closer to
building a bomb that it will have no
choice but
to launch the military action is there a
red line in
iran's production of nuclear capability
that the united states
would say no we cannot rejoin this um
agreement
i i'm not going to uh set a specific
time frame um from the podium certainly
not today
um i think what we can say is what i
said before we want that breakout time
to be as long as possible
we want to make sure that we have
verifiable um
restrictions in place on the type of
activity
that the iranians can undertake that's
precisely why
again starting very early in this
administration um we are setting out
about this challenge uh to make sure
that we can
lengthen uh that breakout time and again
um verifiably prevent iran from ever
obtaining a nuclear weapon to clarify my
question i'm not asking about a timeline
i'm asking about actions
for example iran has also said that it
may not let the iaea
inspect some of its sites would that be
a red line again i
i i would point to the consultations
that were undertaking
the sorts of decisions you're pointing
to um is not something the united states
would want to
um undertake uh alone or would want to
consider or contemplate uh
alone um we entered the iran deal in
2015
um with the p5 plus one um we're uh
uh those um uh
and that those are a set of uh allies
and in a couple cases
um tactical partners uh that we wanna
make sure um
we are coordinating with um again
members of congress as well so
um i don't want to uh set any red lines
from here um certainly not today
um again we're not here to uh negotiate
from the podium we're here
um to undertake those consultations um
in the first instance uh behind closed
doors
do you have a reaction to the icj's
ruling today allowing
iran's lawsuit against the us on
sanctions to move ahead i do i think
um in the first instance i would say
that we have great respect
uh for the international court of
justice um at the same time
we are disappointed that the court did
not accept our well-founded legal
arguments
um that the case iran brought is outside
the court's jurisdiction
uh and the court should not hear it um
while we do not agree with the court's
reasoning
uh today's judgment is a preliminary
ruling not a decision on the merits
uh while iran may seek to frame this
decision as somehow supporting its view
on the merits
the icj's rule uh the ic excuse me
the icj's rules and case law make plain
that a decision on preliminary
objections does not prejudge the merits
uh in the next phase of this case we'll
explain why
iran's claim uh has no merits uh we
remain clear-eyed
about the dangers posed by iran's
malign activities and um that's again
why we are undertaking the important
diplomacy
um that we are uh at the moment and
undertaking those consultations that
i've referred to
still in iran yeah should we stay on
iran just for one second
michelle god the
news reports said that secretary blanken
has asked
iran involved rob mali to form a
negotiating
team made up of diplomats and experts
with a range of views
on the path forward with iran do you
have any names and is the team set
and ready uh to work on for work
so special envoy uh mali uh just started
um late last week on friday uh so this
is
uh literally um day four or so for him
on the job um uh you were right that
the secretary across the board
wants to ensure that our uh thinking
that
um our approach is never dominated by
groupthink um
that we are always uh incorporating uh
an appropriate diversity of views um
uh and of course um that is no different
when it comes to iran as soon as we have
uh additional members of the team to
announce um we'll be happy to
let you know others on a run well just i
just wanted to
get one thing straight here when you're
talking about what uh the secretary said
in his interview that
if left on its current trajectory iran
could be weeks away from getting it does
it not stand to follow
then that also if left on its current
trajectory
iran could be hours away or
minutes away from
from from developing a a weapon i mean
the the
[Music]
the longer it goes without there any
there being any constraints or with that
without iran recognizing or respecting
any constraints doesn't it
doesn't it flow doesn't it follow
naturally that they will get closer and
closer
to to that and so this idea of weeks
it really could be days could be hours
could be
you know minutes right because is that
not
does that not follow logically uh i
i think the the le if if it is
if it continues sure you can take any
argument to the extreme any argument to
be absurd i think uh what we are saying
i don't think it's absurd at all i think
what we are saying here
is that we are approaching this
challenge with urgency
um because we understand uh that with uh
iran
um uh not currently complying um
with its obligations under the jcpoa um
this challenge
uh does uh grow more acute and that's
exactly uh why we are
um undertaking these consultations i
know we've gone on for a little uh
a while um any
last questions
we haven't talked about afghanistan yet
so why don't we um why don't we just do
that briefly
okay um i'm wondering if the secretary
has now seen that full agreement because
he said several times he had to review
it was actually in it um
is there anything in it that surprised
him that he disagrees with
and azal is still on the job what
exactly are his marching orders is he
trying to salvage what's there or are we
starting from scratch again where are
you seeing this
taliban's rejection of uh kirby's
comments from the pentagon last year
well so i think um it's worth starting
with just a broad
survey um and a recap of where the
president is
um and as you have heard the president
say um
he is committed uh to bringing a
responsible uh end to these so-called uh
forever wars
uh these wars that have gone on for uh
nearly two decades
and the biden administration plans to
support the ongoing peace process
between the islamic republic and the
taliban aimed at achieving a just
and durable political settlement and a
permanent and comprehensive
ceasefire we are doing that because we
believe it is the best way to achieve
our objectives
uh we're committed to supporting the
democratic uh
excuse me the diplomatic process uh that
is underway
uh when it comes to the u.s taliban
agreement we're reviewing what has been
negotiating
negotiated including that agreement
the review will include an assessment of
whether the taliban are fulfilling their
commitments to cut ties with terrorist
groups
to reduce violence and to engage in
meaningful negotiations
with the afghan governments and other uh
stakeholders at this time
no decisions about our forced posture
have been made
we are committed as i said supporting
the diplomatic process
and we're committed to ensuring that
afghanistan never
uh again provides a base for terrorist
attacks against the united states
uh our partners or our interests
on the entire agreement though is that
process still uh as i said
the we are reviewing the u.s taliban
agreement
uh let's not go to a new topic anything
else on iran on afghanistan before we
call it today
let's let's just close out in
afghanistan we are doing this uh every
day i should say uh with the caveat that
of course
um we have uh some uh uh vips
um coming our way tomorrow so um we may
not be able to do this briefing tomorrow
but again
um we are gonna plan to do this on a
routine basis
rejected um u.s criticism
that they weren't holding up there under
the agreement do you need to see them
publicly repudiate al-qaeda which they
have not done so far
well uh our review of what was
negotiated with the taliban includes
assessing um
not just what the group has committed to
but what they have done
and what more remains we've had regular
discussions uh with the taliban
regarding implementation of
uh the counterterrorism commitments that
you're referring to um and we'll
continue to do so as that diplomatic
process
uh continues to unfold so with that um
thank you very much everyone and
we will see you third friday if not
sooner
you